this is what near record temperatures
and high winds do here fire spreading at
a hundred acres an hour through the
canyons around San Diego as flames crept
towards multimillion-dollar properties
people living in 20,000 homes were
ordered to pack up and head to safety it
has been to say the least a very
challenging day for local fire agencies
and law enforcement agencies it is
unusual and may to have wind driven
fires like this that proved to be such a
challenge to contain pupils at schools
in the area were also escorted out of
the path of the smoke and flames as fire
crews well used to this kind of
emergency fought to corner the spread of
the fire all of us are working ensure
that we're protecting or San Diego
residents and their homes I also want to
let everyone know that this combined
effort has done everything to marshal
every available resource this is a part
of America parched by the worst drought
for decades and the Santa Ana winds
blowing in hot desert air creates the
ideal conditions for this it is just one
of a number of fires burning across
California right now warnings of more
are in place the last wildfire season
never really ended the new one has only
just begun Greg milam Sky News Los
Angeles